>>Student: Well, in one of our
classes, we had a test that me
and Jason took, and then
when we got it back,
our grades were different although
our answers were pretty much alike.
>>Narrator: These freshmen
at Moanalua High School
in Honolulu are taping a documentary
about their teachers'
grading policies.
>>Student: Well, I was pretty mad,
because mine was marked
down lower and--
>>Narrator: The project is
part of a unique program
that combines the study of English,
social studies and multimedia.
>>Lynne: They were applying
understandings that had come from
"To Kill a Mockingbird,"
that had come from civics,
and the strong emotional reaction to
"Of Mice and Men," trying to think
about in their own world
instances of justice and injustice.
And the whole goal of this is to seek
truth through the video journalism,
and then achieve justice.
>>Student: What is your experience
like working with the ESL students?
>>Woman: I was once an ESL student,
so I know exactly what my students
are going through right now.
>>Student: The reason my group
chose to do this project was
because this subject
really hits close to home.
Everybody in Hawaii has
an immigrant background.
We all came from somewhere
else, but unfortunately,
even if we all are
immigrants in a sense,
we still discriminate against others.
>>Dan: Same thing,
you guys, same thing.
Good, good energy, just keep
the energy up, don't let it dip.
>>Narrator: The concept of
integrating language, social science
and media studies grew
out of an experiment--
[shouting]
>>Narrator: By drama
teacher Dan Hale.
>>Dan: Okay, good, good, good.
>>I had students that basically,
you know, were unmotivated,
sat on their hands, and all a
sudden, I assign this video project,
and all of a sudden, I have a
different student in my class.
You know, they're motivated,
they're spending hours
after that asking me provoking
questions and I'm going,
"Wait a minute, you know,
there's something to this."
And so that's when things
started falling in place.
We started saying,
"Well, how can we kind
of duplicate this on a larger scale?"
>>Student: You'll fill and
I'll do the narrative at home.
>>Narrator: Today, fifty-five
students are involved
in Moanalua's media, communications
and technology integrated
studies program.
>>It just works really well,
because it forces the students
to take the material,
take their resources,
take the data that they learn, and
transform it into another medium,
in the case of video
production or in the case of say,
putting an oral history
onto a website.
They really make it in a way,
they construct new knowledge.
They make it their own
when they have to do that.
>>Bao: In our social studies,
we did our oral history project,
and we researched about
our ancestors,
who are the first immigrants
that came to Hawaii,
and which was my grandma.
And we had to study about
their American dreams,
their country of origin and
like how they got through it.
With all three classes, it gives us a
variety of learning styles and we get
to experience each of the
different classes through media.
>>Narrator: In his first
year in the program,
Bao Lei has already produced an award
winning state history project video,
two shorts for a cable show for
the department of education,
and a video self portrait,
illustrating the concept of metaphor.
>>Bao: Most people say that
Bao is a wild and crazy kid.
>>I was related to a jack
in the box because of
like how I'm usually upbeat
and like to have fun and stuff.
>>Bao is the one who's always
everywhere, and that's why he's
like the jack in the box.
>>Gina: So you use [Japanese]
and [Japanese] is someone
above you, is giving to you, okay?
>>Narrator: Japanese teacher, Gina
Nakahara, sees the new technology
in her classroom as an
asset and a challenge.
>>Gina: I'm very comfortable
with teaching the grammar
and the vocabulary,
introducing the dialog
and having my students practice it.
>>[speaking Japanese]
>>Gina: I can do that with
my eyes closed already.
It's become very routine for me.
But to incorporate the technology
and to bring Japan a little
closer has been challenging,
but I think in the long
run for the students,
it would be that much more
meaningful and exciting for them.
>>Narrator: Nakahara's students have
held online discussions about topics
like the Hiroshima bombing
and communicated directly
with students in Japan.
>>Student: [speaking Japanese]
What it means is, I'm Chen and
this is my senior year high school,
and I'm a bit short, but I
have a cheerful personality
and I wear glasses.
Nice to meet you.
>>Gina: There's a greater world
out there that we're looking at.
Other issues that do affect
them, like nuclear weapons
and the understanding that culture
and language is not a barrier.
It's something that they can
learn and overcome and share.
>>Narrator: Whether they're building
sites for the world wide web,
producing documentaries and cable
television shows, or staging plays,
students seem to put more into their
work when there's an audience for it.
>>Who are you?
>>Man: We show our
work to the school.
We show it on public access,
so that it's not just a matter
of doing a bunch of papers and then
getting a grade back and walking on.
>>Oh no, what am I to do now?
>>Man: They're actually doing
something that's bringing together a
lot of different things and
they do take pride in it.
>>What a curious feeling.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org